Welcome to our Channel please do not
forget to subscribe to our E online
verse Channel hey everyone welcome back
to my E online verse Channel my name is
sham raal today we will explore the
transformative impact of biotechnology
and
agriculture this Dynamic field
integrates biology and Technology to
address critical challenges like food
security environmental sustainability
and climate
resilience before we move forward we
need to understand what biotechnology is
in
agriculture at its core biotechnology
and agriculture involves using
scientific techniques such as genetic
engineering molecular biology and tissue
culture to improve plants animals and
microorganisms for farming unlike
traditional breeding which can take
years biotechnology allows us to make
precise changes at the genetic level to
enhance specific traits it is also
important to understand why
biotechnology and agriculture is
important the demand for food is rising
as the global population approaches 10
billion by
2050 at the same time farmers face
challenges like climate change pests and
limited natural resources biotechnology
offers innovative solutions such as
higher crop yields through pest or
drought resistant plants improved
nutritional content such as biofortified
rice with added vitamin A sustainable
practice
like reducing the need for harmful
pesticides or excessive water use in
this video I will highlight
biotechnology and agriculture Which
shapes Industries and Society across the
globe as part of over 10 series episodes
in this sixth episode I shall dive deep
into biotechnology and agriculture how
it works technological Trends challenges
and opportunities
ahead whether you are a beginner
Enthusiast professional or just someone
curious to learn more this series is
designed to make you aware of
biotechnology and agriculture
worldwide let's get started on this
journey together without further delay
let us dive into biotechnology and
Agriculture and its impactful
developments in the next 15 minutes I
will cover what biotechnology and
agriculture entails key technological
Trends driving Innovation challenges and
opportunities shaping the future of this
field
the first topic of our agenda is what is
biotechnology and
agriculture biotechnology and
agriculture involves using scientific
techniques to modify plants animals and
microorganisms to improve productivity
enhance resistance to diseases and
ensure
sustainability key techniques in
agricultural
biotechnology genetic engineering
altering the DNA of crops for traits
like pest resistance or drought
tolerance example BT cotton tissue
culture growing plant cells and
controlled environments to produce
disease-free plants molecular markers
identifying genes associated with
desirable traits for selective breeding
synthetic biology designing new
biological parts or systems to address
agricultural
challenges the second topic of our
agenda is key technological Trends and
biotechnology for agriculture first Gene
editing with crisp cast 9 what is crisp
arcast 9 a precise Gene editing tool
that enables scientists to modify
specific genes in
Plants applications in
agriculture pest resistance crops with
built-in resistance to Insects reducing
pesticide use drought and climate
resilience modifying crops like rice and
wheat to tolerate water scarcity or
extreme temperatures enhanced nutrition
developing biofortified crops like
golden rice enriched with vitamin A gen
gentically modified organisms GMOs crops
like BT cotton and herbicide resistant
soybeans are engineered for better
productivity and lower environmental
impact biopesticides and biofertilizers
harnessing microorganisms to naturally
protect plants and enrich the soil
examples crisp are edited tomatoes with
extended shelf life Gene edited wheat
resistant to fungal
diseases second biopesticides and
biofertilizers
what are biopesticides and
biofertilizers biopesticides use natural
organisms or substances to control pests
while biofertilizers enhance soil
fertility using beneficial
microbes Trends microbial Solutions
companies are developing microbial
inoculant that promote plant growth and
protect crops from pathogens Precision
application combining biotechnology with
iot for targeted delivery of
biopesticides and biofertilizers
benefits reduced chemical usage improved
soil health and minimized environmental
impact examples basilis thuringensis
BT based biopesticides for Pest Control
micor risal fungi based biofertilizer to
enhance nutrient uptake third genomics
and big data and
agriculture genomics for crop
Improvement advances in DNA sequencing
allow scientists to decode plant genomes
identifying genes responsible for yield
disease resistance and climate
adaptation role of Big Data genomic data
combined with AI and machine learning
helps predict optimal traits for
breeding programs enables Precision
agriculture by analyzing weather soil
and crop data for informed
decisions Example The genome sequencing
of wheat has led to the development of
higher yielding disease resistant
varieties for fourth synthetic biology
and bio-engineered
solutions synthetic biology and
agriculture engineering biological
systems to create entirely innovative
solutions such as nitrogen fixing crops
or bio-engineered plant-based meat
Alternatives Trends development of crops
that produce their fertilizer by fixing
nitrogen from the air bioengineered
algae for sustainable biofuels and
animal
feed examples synthetic rice for ities
with enhanced yields and nutritional
content algae based animal feed to
reduce methane emissions in
livestock fifth ARA interference
technology what is Rai a natural
biological process where RNA molecules
inhibit gene expression effectively
silencing specific
genes applications in agriculture Pest
Control through RNA based sprays that
Target pests without harming beneficial
insects disease resistance by silencing
genes that pathogens use to infect
plants example RI based sprays protect
crops like potatoes and corn from viral
and fungal
diseases the second topic of our agenda
is challenges and
opportunities first let me share the
challenges in biotechnology and
agriculture
challenges regulatory hurdles stringent
regulations for genetically modified
organisms GMOs can delay the adoption of
Biotech crops
public perception concerns about food
safety and environmental impact often
lead to resistance Against Biotech
Innovations accessibility and Equity
prohibitive costs of biotechnology May
exclude small holder farmers in
developing
regions environmental concerns
overreliance on certain biotech
Solutions such as the monoculture of GM
crops can lead to biodiversity loss
biotechnology often raises questions
about safety and ethics however rigorous
testing and Regulatory Frameworks ensure
that biotech products are safe for
humans animals and the environment
education and transparent communication
play a key role in addressing public
concerns despite so many challenges
there are still a lot of opportunities
in biotechnology and
agriculture sustainable agriculture
biotechnology reduces the need for
harmful chemicals promoting
environmentally friendly farming
practices food secur
biotech crops with higher yields and
resilience to climate change can address
Global hunger climate change mitigation
engineered plants can capture more
carbon dioxide or produce renewable
biofuels reducing greenhouse gas
emissions personalized agriculture using
Ai and biotech tools farmers can
cultivate crops tailored to specific
soil conditions climates and consumer
preferences the future of agricultural
biotechnology is exciting
emerging Innovations like Gene drives to
control pests or synthetic biology to
create entirely new biological systems
could revolutionize farming these tools
will be essential in building a
resilient sustainable and secure Global
Food
system before I conclude this topic my
final thoughts biotechnology and
agriculture is at the Forefront of
innovation addressing critical
challenges like food security climate
change and
sustainability trends like crisper
synthetic biology and biopesticides are
reshaping the future of
farming the fusion of biotechnology and
agriculture is not just about growing
more food it is about growing smarter
healthier and more sustainable food for
a growing global
population in summary biotechnology and
agriculture combines science and
Innovation to tackle pressing Global
challenges it holds the potential to not
only secure our food supply but also
create a more sustainable and Equitable
future for all I would be happy to
answer any questions or discuss the
exciting future of biotechnology and
agriculture that might impact your field
of Interest please leave comments in the
comment section thank you for your
attention please stay tuned for my
seventh episode on autonomous vehicles
which I promise will be exciting and
insightful I am sure you do not want to
miss it if you like this video please
hit that subscribe button and join the E
online verse family today and don't
forget to click the notification Bell so
you'll always be the first to know when
we drop something new your support means
the world to us and it helps us create
even better content for you let's grow
and Thrive together in the E online
verse
Channel thank you for watching and we'll
see you in the next video